[Music]
so good evening everyone thank you to the
trust program for trusting us
precisely and thank you for inviting us to
pity this evening including cocktails and it is
a sensor simulation software publishing company
created in 2001 and
based  in the Toulouse region, so our
simulation workshop the sbh makes it possible to
generate physically realistic synthetic sensor data,
so this data
can be, for example,
visible or infrared images of
lidar point clouds or radar or gps signals
is therefore one of the particularities of our
tools  it is from this aspect
representativeness and physical realism
therefore this realism it has been proven for
more than twenty years during
experimental campaigns and measurements with
laboratories such as onera or fran
offered a certainty but also by
state defense agencies
so besides our solution today
is exploited as a reference solution
there already for the qualification  ion
of guidance and navigation detection systems
which uses all or part
of the sensors mentioned we are also working
on the same models with other
state agencies internationally,
particularly in europe and asia where a
very strong presence which also uses
our solutions as a reference solution
on the industrial side we work on
industrialists use our tools for the
development of these same applications
in the field of defense, space,
civil aeronautics or
transport, therefore automotive or
rail, whatever we want  to trust in
the project is to use our
tools to generate debts with this
aesthetic so dates to seven which
are composed of
physically realistic synthetic sensor data
since well in simulation in fact we
can build the perfect learning game
a simulation we
complete control of the content of the data we
control the amount of data that we
generate and we can  generating labeling data
with any type of label from
the simplest to the most advanced
is therefore what we actually expect from the
program is to be able to help
us accompany us to build a
process
two generations of synthetic data
that will come as a result  improve the
performance of trusted neural networks
and for this we hope to be able to
rely on the scientific expertise
there are academic members of the project
and the business expertise of
industrialists who will come to
actually confront this approach with
their younger business uses
here  but thank you once
again and we can't wait to start this project
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]